hey so Chex Mix came to me and asked me
to review their videogame chexquest
HD now as you all know I'm really not
good at video games
I suck at them to be honest but they
asked me to review the game anyway well
we're in quarantine so I reached out to
the only expert gamers that I know Aaron
Blair and Sonya Reed aka Firefox wish I
had that nickname to review the game hey
everybody what's going on play here and
I'm here with Firefox aka Sonya Reid and
I'm very excited let's get into it oh
there's stairs horrified stairs piercing
very intense I was misunderstood I
thought you were a gamer and you're at
30% home already
that's right I'm coming at you with a
spoon dude don't spoon me you've got a
giant Chuck's head Raina never see it
coming
hello eyes or Chee right in your stupid
head eyes or CH they're right back I
think if we had to rate the game in the
game when you you fire a thing it's
called as Archer and use or Cheech other
and so I think how many's or CH is out
of 10 do we give this on you
I mean I'm up all of my searches on you
so I if I had any left I would give it a
10 out of 10 searches but I'm all out so
during this global pandemic what the
three of us are focusing on right now is
how many searches you can fire
effectively is that what we're doing yes
you can watch our full segment on Team
Coco twitch chexquest
HD by Chex Mix is Bill now with
multiplayer for free on Steam I don't
understand that sentence